the jurogan experience the other thing i
like about this place is that we were
talking about before that it's a blue
city surrounded by a red state
i love that it keeps it in check sure
you know it's there's there's something
about that
and it's just uh this whole town it's
like texas itself is a very rebellious
place and this is where kinnison started
and this is where bill hicks started
sure and there's something about that
that's like that's it's baked into their
appreciation for comedy i mean those
guys put texas on the map as far as
comedy because people thought about
comedy they thought of new york
thought of la maybe san francisco maybe
chicago
boston for sure but they didn't think of
houston and two of the best of all time
came out of houston houston's a great
comedy city and also
you look at the you can tell their texas
comics because
religion is such a big part of both
their acts yeah and you feel that that's
like the texan in them i mean i i
connect i mean bill hicks is
he's like the biggie smalls of comedy
because the amount of work he did it's
gold and he died so [ __ ] young he
liked five albums dude i think he died
at like 34 or something something like
that pancreatic cancer and you re-listen
to those albums dude those albums
whenever comics call bill hicks
overrated i'm like you're a [ __ ]
idiot bill hicks is great and he and you
know what's great about bill hicks so
many comics now with his ideology would
only perform in like sf and portland and
burlington vermont that dude's doing
he's taking that act to alabama
that's [ __ ] cool that's why he's
bombing so he did the road constantly oh
dude the flying saucer tour when you're
like he's those albums i'm dying
laughing too you're listening to one of
the greatest comics of all time bombing
and he released this for us
he's [ __ ] bombing he's he's calling
the crowd dumb yeah and it's not like
just some comics it's a great comic
calling crowds dumb there's something
beautiful about that he's so [ __ ]
angry on stage but it was like beautiful
anger it was earned anger well
everything was interesting even if he
was bombing what he was saying was
interesting
brilliant yeah it was just in that was
like one of his tenets of comedy is uh
even if you're not going to be funny be
interesting he was lenny bruce for us i
listen to lenny bruce and i'm like it's
a little it doesn't resonate for me i
understand that he's brilliant i
understand we that we need him but like
bill hicks was like that for guys like
us who were like we
he made it he made it cool you know he
made you feel like a hack
like you were just telling jokes and he
was up there talking about young man on
acid thought he could fly you know like
to write about positive drug stories
yeah that's a brilliant brilliant bit
it's a brilliant bit it's a pro-drug bit
from a guy who was clean and sober at
the time
you know he's talking about the great
times that he had when he's doing drugs
i mean it was also everything was so
well worded it was so smart
you know it was uh it was just a
completely interesting kind of comedy
and it changed so many people's way of
comedy to the point where the punch line
in atlanta when you had performed there
in the green room somebody wrote in the
green room quit trying to be hicks yeah
yeah he had his rules of comedy and he
also some of them i'm like all right he
was like never asked the crowd how
they're doing i'm like that one's hard
we can get we can do that that's fine so
many people imitated him was what the
point of quit trying to be hicks was of
course they were all trying to do that
they were all trying to be him
you know and they would go on stage with
some [ __ ] half big point
about the government or taxes or
something they they it's like so often
with great comics
you miss what the beauty of them was is
that
hicks at his core was silly and funny
and when he got self-righteous that's
kind of when he lost me sometimes when
he was like kind of condescending in the
crowd i was kind of like i don't love
this as much as when you're just doing
great jokes like i love that bit he does
i love you know
it's in his half hour on hbo and he's
like i i hate when uh
i love watching people in aspen smoke
cigarettes not knowing they're done
inhaling and he does the act out and he
just keeps blowing because of the smoke
and it's like that's a great [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah that's a silly observational
joke and you're like oh that dude was
great at
political stuff social commentary
religious stuff but then he could just
do a [ __ ] observational bit yeah he's
one of the all-time greats so when
people write him off as being overrated
it's all in the context of time you have
to think about it that way if you go and
listen to lenny bruce it doesn't make
any sense to us because everything has
already been understood and covered like
all the things that he's talking about
that are groundbreaking
back then they were people like what is
oh my god what is happening like this
guy's breaking down society no one can
do this
no one had done that before but now
everybody does it so when you hear him
do it and then the things he's saying
the world has moved on so much from 1963
today that it's impossible to like it's
impossible to he still had some jokes
that worked today he had one joke he
goes you know it's against the law to be
homosexual so what do they do they put
you in jail with a bunch of men who want
to have sex with you that's a great bit
it's a great bit
and that's a bit from like what 65 or
something that's the thing it's like
it's like watching basketball in the 60s
and you're like seeing chamberlain and
you're like well there's no jordan
without this [ __ ] exactly and you know
who's jordan carl and pryor right yeah
so you got to take pride also i love
that he was like a cool jew
like so often like jews are like oh boy
i'm [ __ ]
i i love when how often did cool jews
pop up and show but like he's one of the
coolest one of the coolest elliot gould
i was like grateful for elliot gould i'm
like guys like that and i'm like well
you're not just doing the oh shucks my
my [ __ ] i'm so nervous and i have
allergies i'm like no be [ __ ] be like
be yourself you be cool is jeff goldblum
jewish i don't know that's a name is
jewish as [ __ ] that's a jewish name he's
a cool guy he's a very cool guy that's
what he's going to get to great [ __ ]
he's a smart science guy i've been
rewatching larry sanders and he's so
[ __ ] funny he's great and everything
that's a great show he's great as the
scientist in jurassic park yes he's
jewish there you go cool jewish guy cool
yeah but lenny bruce was like
he was uh he was a
real pioneer like there was no other i
mean there was mort saul who was doing
political but he doesn't get his shine
no he just passed away i mean he he's
tall yeah yeah mortal didn't get a shine
because he was so of his time like the
guy holding the newspaper when like
lenny bruce broke through was mort saul
i guess you know the problem is
sometimes you live too long you you you
ain't che guevara if you live till
[ __ ] 78 right you're che guevara when
you die in your prime right and your and
your young picture is shown everywhere
right but when you live too long
sometimes it ain't as cool yes right
that's cool so a guy like lenny bruce
died in the most romantic way possible
heroin overdose on the bathroom floor
yeah that's what you want from that kind
you want to go out like hendrix or
janice joplin that's when you become
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
i mean bill hicks too like who knows
maybe he would have had a shitty podcast
maybe he would have been great who the
[ __ ] knows how people age right
i think he would have been great he
would have been great he was never not i
don't i don't think i mean imagine if he
had like a like hbo show where he just
did like like almost like bill maher's
style where he just did that you're like
whoa that'd be [ __ ] cool huh do you
know who had a great story about him
carrot top really because bill used to
make fun of him and carrot tops act
or in bill hicks actually make fun of
carrot top brother and he had this bit
about uh he goes yeah carrot top it's
for people who think he goes uh
gallagher's too heady
was just a prop joke yeah and um carrick
scott carrot top is a [ __ ] sweetheart
of a guy he's heard he's the man he's
so cool and
i always felt like he got [ __ ] with
for no reason like his act is funny it's
funny [ __ ] but he was always like a
punch line to comedians like that he was
not one of us not a real comic [ __ ] him
and it was always like people would [ __ ]
all over carrot top i don't think norm
did him any favors in that interview and
he just kept trashing him because norm
was so cool that i think like when you
see a guy as cool as norm doing that
right i think it hurts well it hurts if
you're sensitive right like if you're a
comic and someone's trashing you it
should be funny yeah there should be
some humor to it you know what i mean
yeah but sometimes guys get isolated and
he was very scott's very isolated you
know he's out there
in the world on his own not really
connected to comics in the same way
so hicks before he died was really sick
and uh he
came to one of scott's shows so carrot
top's doing a show
and hicks came to the show and hung he
wanted those last few months to last
forever
he goes no man i don't [ __ ] hate you
it's just jokes i'm sorry